foreign
hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear coming up on Halloween the big day
and uh so in the lead up to Halloween
I was looking for some movies that were
kind of like more in a classic stately
autumnal kind of vibe like ones that I
hadn't seen before perhaps something new
so when I was scrolling through all of
the stuff on shutter I noticed that
there was a 2022 movie uh that shutter
recently added I believe it was the at
the end of September and it was called
Ravens Hollow and this seemed to be
exactly the kind of movie that I was
looking for
so this was directed by Christopher
Hatton uh who also he's done like
several movies but um I think the
probably the best known one was from
2013 it was called Battle of the Damned
like an action movie with Dolph Lundgren
but this movie in particular is a very
very gloomy kind of dreary period piece
and it's kind of like giving you a story
about like a fanciful and horrific event
in the life of a relatively young Edgar
Allan Poe like obviously before he was
famous which would go on to explain like
why he wrote about such morbid subjects
like later on in his life uh the movie
definitely provided some of these spooky
fall Vibes that I was looking for it's
very kind of like it's not set at
Halloween necessarily but it is set in
the Autumn so it has that kind of like
vibe to it uh and it also had some
really cool Gore overall for me though I
think it fell kind of like right in the
middle of the spectrum like it wasn't
like great but it wasn't like it wasn't
bad but it wasn't great you know what I
mean it was just kind of like maybe like
a solid six somewhere around there like
I said if I gave numerical scores which
I don't usually because like I said I
think it's kind of productive but that's
where it would fall about in the middle
so it's pretty easy to see why it's
called Raven's Hollow not only because
you know duh at Ground lapo The Raven
and so forth but also because it has
kind of like a folkloric angle that sort
of somewhat recalls uh you know the
Washington Irving story Legend of Sleepy
Hollow now the cinematography and the
set design and the color palette of this
movie actually also somewhat recalls Tim
Burton's 1999 adaptation which was just
called Sleepy Hollow although I will say
that the um that the kind of Hues in
Raven's Hollow are a lot more subdued
like it's a lot more kind of just like
blue green gray
um without like a lot of I mean I guess
there is kind of bloody it's not it's
not as over the top as you know Tim
Burton's is but it's kind of like a
similar kind of look to it so at the
beginning of the story uh it's 18 30.
and Edgar Allan Poe who is played by
William Mosley who looked kind of
familiar he's been in a couple things
that I've seen
um I think he was in a friend request uh
which I saw but I think he played Peter
in The Chronicles of Narnia movies so
maybe I think I maybe saw the first one
of those and maybe that's where I'm
recognizing him from but he's playing
Edgar Allan Poe and he's on a training
exercise with a bunch of his fellow West
Point Cadets which is true like Ed
ground Poe did get a West Point uh and
they're in Upstate New York like doing
field exercises or whatever
Now by chance uh they happen upon a very
grisly scene there's kind of like this
tree-like structure that sort of
resembles a bird type situation and on
that thing is a man who's kind of like
bound on there like almost kind of like
a crucifixion or like a sacrificial kind
of pose uh worse than that even the man
has been completely disemboweled and uh
horribly is still clinging to life even
though his intestines are like literally
like hanging out of his body uh now
before he dies he actually only speaks a
single word and that single word is
Raven now most of the cadets uh probably
understandably do not want to get
involved with whatever
grotesque [ __ ] business this might be
but Poe is pretty adamant that this is
their job they really have to like take
the man to the nearest Village it's the
right thing to do they have to find out
not only who he is but who exactly
killed him and why
so in the course of this endeavor the
men actually find this small settlement
that's called obviously Raven's Hollow
and when they arrive a funeral is taking
place and the funeral is actually like
of this little girl that you saw a die
like in a really weird like [ __ ] up
way like at the beginning of the movie
like in the prologue now Poe gets there
and he asks if anybody knows who this
dead man is that he's carried back to
this Village on the back of his horse
but everybody in the town denies knowing
him it's pretty clear though that
they're all hiding something and so Poe
gets kind of like offended by the whole
thing like these [ __ ] they
totally know something uh and they're
not telling me so he takes it upon
himself to try and figure out what it is
that they're keeping from him so him and
the other guys they check into the
villages only in it's you know like I
said it's a very small settlement and
Poe actually kind of I don't want to go
too far in this direction but he does
kind of like start making eyes at this
sort of charming like young woman named
Charlotte he's played by Melanie Zanetti
uh who is a very like forthright and
she's kind of like morbidly curious like
she comes up to see the body like I'll
be okay just let me see it like almost
like she's like she's a little too
excited about it so he kind of digs that
but on the other hand she also acts like
super sauce just like everybody else in
the town does now before the cadets
retire for their first night in town
There's a stable hand named Usher and he
tells them that um you know you guys had
better get gone if you know what's good
for you because the village is haunted
by some kind of creature that everybody
just refers to as the Raven That's all
they'll say is like well it's not a bird
and it's not a person uh that's but
that's all they'll say about it now the
men of course you know they're they
scoff at this Supernatural nonsense uh
that is until one of their number
mysteriously disappears in the night
leaving only a severed hand to remember
him by so after that Edgar Allan Poe is
on the case uh which I kind of liked
because that foreshadows the detective
fiction genre that the real Edgar Allan
Poe would essentially invent
um so operating under the assumption
that a human killer is responsible for
the deaths and disappearances which of
course you probably would Poe attempts
to get to the bottom of this mounting
series of crimes like more people are
turning up dead more of his guys are
like disappearing and turning up dead
um and all the while he's kind of being
stymied by the very cagey villagers who
obviously know a great deal more about
what's going on than they're willing to
tell him so much like Tim Burton's
Sleepy Hollow uh this movie is kind of
like a very Bleak Moody historical
horror that mixes a detective story with
the supernatural now unlike uh Tim
Burton's Sleepy Hollow though um there's
no humor in this because Sleepy Hollow
like had like some funny uh kind of
stuff to it this one is not funny it's
very very serious and I will say too
that there's not really a lot of mystery
to unravel for the viewer in this movie
because we're pretty sure from the very
beginning that the Raven is a real
monster of some kind or at any rate that
there is something like Supernatural
going on but it's still interesting to
watch the story play out now I will
admit though that I found the lore like
surrounding the creature to be a tad
convoluted and a little bit difficult to
parse like once it was all laid out but
you know it makes sense but you just
kind of like wait what you know what I
mean it's kind of like that uh also I'll
say the CGI on the creature and in a few
other scenes is not the best but it's
serviceable enough for the story and you
know wisely they kept it to a minimum I
mean you can tell this is a fairly low
budget it looks really really nice for a
low budget movie but you can tell that
the CGI isn't like top-notch CGI you
know what I mean so there's not a ton of
it in there and that was probably like a
good idea uh also one thing that I did
like about this was that there was a
great deal of Gore most of which looked
practical and it was like just super
like awesomely gooey uh one particular
scene of a completely like torn apart
body just strewn all over the altar of
the village church was a definite
highlight it was like super disgusting
and I think it was like really really
well done also for the most part the
acting was very good William Mosley I
think he did a good job as Edgar Allan
Poe and some of the other like more
veteran actors that are in this like
Kate Dickey who plays Charlotte's Mother
Elizabeth uh were great I will say that
some of the actors with some of like the
more minor roles like some of the other
Cadets and stuff um you know came off a
tad stagey but nothing too distracting
so all in all like I said this is a very
decent period horror if you're looking
for that kind of harvest time in New
England sort of ambiance like I said to
kind of gear up for Halloween or
whatever or if you're really into Edgar
Allan Poe and want to see like us you
know kind of a serious Supernatural tale
that attempts to explain the author's
later Macabre proclivities I guess now
some of the poe references seemed a
little shoehorned in like the stable
hand who's actually like a major
character uh being named Usher for
example and there's like a flat
flashback like that features a girl
named Lenore that was like somebody's
sister or whatever but it was still like
pretty and a pretty amusing diversion I
guess to try and pick out all the poe
Easter eggs that had been you know woven
into the story I mean this isn't the
best like Poe as a fictional character
movie that I've ever seen because you
know there's more than one of those
Believe It or Not uh but it's definitely
worth a watch if you're kind of into
gory Gothic Victorian kind of stuff like
I said if you like Sleepy Hollow then
you'll probably like this because it's
along the same lines although it's not
funny so that will do it for this
flickers of fear uh let me know if
you've seen this movie in the comments
what you thought about it what are you
guys watching in the lead up to
Halloween let me know also in the
comments and I will see you guys again
on the next one bye